considera el siguiente experimento
tenemos dos pedazos de metal cobre y
zinc que vamos a conectar usando cables
conductores y ahora sumergimos los
metales en un electrolito en este caso
vinagre
observarán que se forman burbujas
alrededor del zinc
pero no en el cobre los metales lucen
diferentes de esta manera si ahora
unimos los cables que conectan a ambos
metales algo cambia se empiezan a formar
pequeñas burbujas alrededor de la
terminal de cobre pareciera que algo es
jalado del zinc a través del cable y
resulta que este es un flujo de carga
eléctrica conforme los electrones son
jalados lejos del zinc hacia el cobre a
través de la ruta conductora de los
cables imaginen este flujo como
resultado de un desequilibrio de cargas
o presión eléctrica entre los dos
metales comparemos la descarga
instantánea que observamos con los
experimentos de electricidad estática
a finales del siglo 18 alessandro volta
había estado investigando este efecto
más importante aún se dio cuenta de que
si se encadenaban estas celdas se
amplificaba este flujo de carga y para
1800 el simplificó más aún las cosas
eliminando la jarra que estaba
proporcionando más electrolitos de los
necesarios él escribió que algunas
docenas de discos de cobre por ejemplo
estas monedas junto con un número igual
de piezas de zinc él preparó pedazos de
material esponjoso capaces de retener
agua así que emparejó un pedazo de cobre
con un pedazo de zinc siempre con el
mismo orden y siempre ponía un pedazo de
material húmedo entre estos discos y
continuó haciendo esto hasta tener una
columna lo más alta posible sin que se
cayeran esto es famosamente conocido
como la pila voltaica la primera batería
o pila en la historia en tener un flujo
continuo de carga eléctrica o corriente
si se agregaban más celdas aumentaba la
presión eléctrica de la corriente
resultaban en el aumento de la presión
eléctrica en ambos extremos y la presión
eléctrica fue uno de los primeros
términos para referirse a lo que ahora
conocemos como voltaje llamado así en
honor a volta
si ambos cables en los extremos de la
pila se tocan se tocan de forma directa
podremos observar una serie de choques o
chispas
al principio el uso de la corriente
eléctrica como método de comunicación no
fue algo obvio inmediatamente solo se
observaban chispas y burbujas una idea
fue usar la presencia de burbujas para
representar letras y el telégrafo de
burbujas usó este método aunque
involucraba 26 circuitos diferentes uno
para cada letra y se basaba en el hecho
de que la batería o la pila que
proporcionaba la corriente podía
colocarse alejada de las jarras o de los
recipientes que contenían las terminales
que producían las burbujas fue un
invento ingenioso aunque no muy práctico
y nunca se usó pero pronto todo
cambiaría después de una famosa
demostración en 1819 se encontró que si
pasábamos un cable cerca de una brújula
y conectábamos este cable a una pila en
el instante en el que el cable hace
contacto con la pila se movía la aguja
sin tener contacto físico alguno la
única explicación era que la corriente
que era llevada por el cable creaba un
campo magnético temporal a esto le
siguieron varias pruebas para descubrir
la dirección de este campo primero se
pensó que apuntaba a lo largo del cable
que llevaba la corriente o quizá
emanando hacia afuera del cable de la
misma manera que viaja el calor pero
después se descubrió que estaba viajando
alrededor del cable en círculos
perpendiculares así que un lazo de cable
crearía un campo magnético que apunta a
través del centro de este lazo girando
hacia afuera esto se convirtió en un
galvano metro que se diseñó para
detectar y medir corriente eléctrica
simplemente era un rollo de cable o una
bobina con una brújula suspendida en el
centro cuando se aplicaba corriente
eléctrica a la bobina o al cable
enrollado se creaba un campo magnético
al centro del cable rodea
solo por afuera de manera que la aguja
siempre apuntaba de forma perpendicular
a la dirección de la fuerza que se
encontraba en equilibrio a ambos lados
de la aguja y mientras más fuerte era la
corriente más grande sería el movimiento
o el desplazamiento de la aguja y para
1824 william stirling demostró una forma
de aumentar la fuerza de este campo
simplemente enrollando un cable
conductor alrededor de un pedazo de
acero que podría ser un clavo se podría
amplificar la fuerza magnética porque el
acero es un mejor medio para apoyar la
formación de un campo magnético a esto
le llamamos permeabilidad y al enrollar
varias veces el cable alrededor del
clavo se puede aumentar la fuerza del
campo miles de veces esto se conoce como
un electroimán
así que de pronto era posible crear un
campo magnético que podía mover agujas
con precisión y fuerza
usando una corriente eléctrica aplicada
a la distancia usando un cable enrollado
largo y una batería potente en ese
entonces nuestra comprensión de la
información estaba en sus inicios las
personas pensaban en la información de
un mensaje como el número de letras en
un mensaje así que la meta era intuitiva
ver quién podía encontrar una forma
rápida de transmitir letras y quien
tuviera el sistema más rápido entonces
podría reducir el costo por mensaje para
el receptor usando este sistema y una
mina de oro esperaba para aquella
persona que lograra hacer esto primero